-[Sandi] Now...
-Chop, chop.
...the bakers take on
a trio of desserts.
We're gonna put some cherries on top.
[Sandi] With a Signature
that's all about the swirl...
[Ruby] Roll, baby, roll.
[Manon] No. It's cracking.
[whimpers]
...tackle a '70s classic technical...
[Karen] Oh, what a mess.
It's not looking good.
...and attempt a mesmerizing
melting chocolate masterpiece...
[exhales] This is as nerve-wracking
as blooming giving birth.
...that's never before been witnessed.
Ah, yes! Amazing.
[Ruby gasps] Oh, no, it's cracked.
You've gotta laugh about these things,
haven't you, eh?
[laughs tearfully] And cry a little bit.
I'm all right. I'm fine.
[theme music playing]
[sheep bleating]
Noel, what are you doing?
It's dessert week.
I've made a custard pie.
Are you kidding me?
Do you remember last year
when Paul accidentally
got a custard pie in the face?
We cannot risk having that happen again.
It was a disaster. Give me that.
-I'm gonna throw it--
-Sandi. Noel.
-[gasps] Oh!
-Welcome to dessert week.
-[whispers] What should we do?
-Run!
[Briony] I've definitely been
looking forward to this week,
and that's probably my signing
my death warrant, right there.
[Ruby] I think I've just about managed
to scrape through every single week,
so let's go for nailing
a good signature today.
So far, I haven't had
a big baking disaster,
so hopefully, it's gonna continue?
Week four. It's getting
quite into the competition now.
Dan's looking strong. Rahul definitely.
He just seems to be, like,
a culinary magician or something.
It's a mixture of everything, really.
Scary, exciting
nervous. But, in the morning,
what better way to start
than with a glass of milk?
So I just literally drink a glass of milk
in the morning.
Hello, bakers. Welcome back to the tent.
Now, as you all know, unfortunately,
Terry is not with us today
because he is poorly,
but with the agreement
of absolutely everybody,
he is going to be allowed
to come back next week.
Right, on with the challenge.
Today, the judges would love you
to make a meringue roulade.
Now, your roulade
needs to be family-sized.
and must be made
from melt-in-the-mouth meringue.
[Sandi] The choice of filling?
Entirely up to you, but the filling
must be enclosed in the roulade,
which, when cut,
must demonstrate a perfect swirl.
You have one hour and 45 minutes.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
Bake.
[Jon] It's too quiet.
-It's making my nerves go weird.
-[Dan] Everyone's separating eggs.
[Ruby] It's my wost bit that
you need to concentrate on.
[Karen] I've managed to get the egg whites
in the bowl
without getting any egg yolk in.
That was the first hurdle, passed.
Oh, yeah, I messed it up. Oh...
This is annoying.
[Paul] What we're looking for
in a great roulade,
crack through the exterior,
soft on the inside
and beautiful spiral into the middle.
[Prue] One of the things the bakers
really need to think about
is the balance of flavours.
You need a bit of acidity,
either a curd or nice sharp fruits
because meringue is pure sugar.
But the beauty of this challenge is,
there's nowhere to hide.
Make a mistake and it shows up.
[Dan] And there's four whites in there.
Meringue's the most important thing.
Just got to get it in the oven
as quickly as possible.
[Kim-Joy] You want just
a nice, stiff, glossy meringue.
Like, no undissolved sugar in it.
[Manon] I think it's hot enough now.
-Hello.
-[Manon] Hello.
Hello, Manon.
So, how are you making your meringue?
I heat the sugar in the oven.
Basically just dissolves much quicker
in the egg whites.
With everything I'm doing, I'm hopefully
guaranteeing a good meringue.
[Sandi] Manon's relying
on her heated sugar
to perfect a meringue that will wrap
a mascarpone cream
with kirsch soaked dark cherries
and amarene cherries.
Amarene, this is like Italian, sweet,
almondy cherries,
and it's a flavour from my childhood.
Do you want to smell?
[Noel] Thought that was an urn.
Fantastic. They smell like almond kernels,
don't they?
And you've done this before?
Uh, never made a meringue roulade before.
So...
[Briony] Slowly. Slowly.
You don't want to just dump it all in
'cause you don't want the egg whites
to lose their air. Well, my husband's
favourite childhood dessert
was treacle tart,
so I've basically... It's the filling that
you would have in a treacle tart,
but in a roulade.
[Noel] In addition, Briony will add
a layer of chopped,
fresh and dried pears, and wrap it all up
in a pecan meringue.
How many pears you gonna be using?
-Um, three.
-Okay.
[Briony laughs] Oh! You carry on.
[Paul] Love pears.
I love pears. They're underrated.
Yeah. Absolutely.
Who's their press officer?
They're getting nothing.
[Karen] Yeah, that's the meringue
nearly done.
I'm just making sure
that it holds its own shape.
That, um, if I wanted to risk it
over the top of my head,
it wouldn't fall out of the bowl.
Yeah, that's fine.
Yeah, we're okay.
So, I think it's there.
Meringues are like clouds, aren't they?
They make you think of dreams.
So we're doing like
a dream-themed one of, like,
moons and star biscuits on top.
[Noel] Kim-Joy's bedtime roulade
will be filled with whipped cream,
fresh raspberries
and a passion fruit curd.
[Noel] Love that you always have a theme.
What do you dream about?
Last night, I dreamt I woke up at 11:00,
and I missed.
I had a dream that I was with Sandi
where she was playing a bull,
and I had a serviette
and we were doing bull-fighting.
[all laugh]
[Jon] I'm just spreading my meringue.
I prefer the sheet to using the tins.
I find it's a more rustic edge to it.
Use the word "rustic",
you can get away with anything.
[Sandi] Jon's exotic roulade
will be filled with passion fruit curd
and white chocolate cream
and topped with a decoration
that requires scientific precision.
With some mango spheres on the top.
What do you mean, mango spheres?
Mango spheres,
spherification of mango juice.
It's like an egg yolk. You burst 'em,
and then the sauce comes out of them.
Cute little extra to
put on the top of your roulade.
-Good luck then, Jon.
-Thank you very much.
Thank you.
It's a meringue. I think it's good.
[Noel] When baking a roulade,
there's no room for error.
So that's going in the oven.
[Noel] Just a minute too long,
the meringue will be too dry,
and it'll crack when it's rolled.
I'm baking it for 160 for 30 minutes.
[Sandi] Underbaked, and it'll be too soft,
and the whole roulade will collapse.
I am, slightly, going to underbake it
only because I have past experiences
of meringues breaking open.
I want it to be slightly rollable.
I hope. I wish. I don't know. Oh...
Right, Next step. Next step. Next step.
[Sandi] Making a roulade
now gets even harder.
I'm just doing so many things
at the same time.
I feel a little bit running around.
[Sandi] The bakers need to use every
minute their meringue is in the oven...
[Ruby] I've actually just poured in
way too much booze into that. Oops.
[Sandi] ...to perfect
their all-important fillings.
Did you learn knife skills?
No, I just, literally, watch
and learn from TV
-or, like, YouTube and things like that.
-Oh! Life hacks.
[Sandi] The texture
of the filling is critical.
Passion fruit curd. Just waiting for it
to thicken a little bit more.
[Noel] Too thick, it will be impossible
to roll the meringue
and create the perfect swirl.
[Briony] This is the treacle tart filling.
That's just dried breadcrumbs
in golden syrup.
[Noel] Too runny...
Oops! [laughs]
...the filling will spill out,
resulting in a soggy roulade.
You don't want liquid because then
it's just, like... Blech! It's not nice.
[Noel] And they need to get the balance
of flavours just right.
Meringue is, like, really sweet.
It's all sugar.
And I think you need something sharp.
I spent quite a lot of time
in the Florida Keys,
and I started thinking about
the flavours that I've enjoyed.
They're mainly cocktails, if I'm being
completely honest with you.
[Sandi] Dan's fruity roulade
will be filled with a coconut cream,
topped with fresh mango,
strawberries and lime curd.
[Dan] The lime is really
the star of this one.
I think I've got the balance
of the sweetness and the sharpness right.
Let's all cross our fingers.
[Sandi] Dan's not the only baker
to be studying the cocktail menu.
My roulade today is inspired by
the years that I lived in Liverpool.
Had a lot of good times
with my friends going out.
So I'm doing a piña colada.
That classic Liverpool cocktail.
Paul actually bought me a piña colada
the other day. True story.
Ruby's "girls night out" roulade
will have a boozy coconut-cream filling,
layered with roasted pineapple,
all rolled up in a coconut meringue.
I'm making a piña colada
on the side as well.
Can you make four? Three for Prue
-and one for me.
-[all laughing]
-[Paul] All right, thank you.
-Thank you very much.
[Rahul] I was introduced to rhubarb
when I first came here.
I hated it because it's just so sharp.
But then I had rhubarb and custard.
So this is like
one of the first British flavour
that I've grown into liking.
[Sandi] Rahul will roll
a classic rich-cream custard
and rhubarb compote
in a flaked-almond-decorated meringue.
Did you not win star baker twice in a row?
Oh, my God. Do you have to say that?
I think you can get three in a row.
I'm not thinking that, you know.
[Noel] If you get three in a row,
I'm gonna get on your shoulders
and you carry me round the tent, yeah?
Well, that's definitely, probably
not gonna happen, after you said that.
When you get a box of chocolates
at Christmas in the family,
coffee creams and hazelnut pralines
always go first in our house.
So I've tried to base the flavours
on that, really.
[Noel] Karen's festive roulade
will be flavoured with a hazelnut praline,
coffee caramel
and a rich, creamy whiskey filling.
[Karen] This is a very thick custard.
If it's sloppy, it will just ooze out.
That's fine.
Curd's done.
It's just gonna go in the fridge.
Bakers, you are halfway through
your signature challenge.
You have 52 and a half minutes left.
[Dan laughs] That's oddly specific.
I'm looking for a crispy coating
with a nice creamy centre.
He's rising. He's rising.
Two or three minutes till the meringue
comes out the oven.
I think I'm taking it out now.
[Dan] Coming out in, like, four minutes.
I just hope
it's not going to crack too much.
I'm gonna go for two minutes more,
and then he's coming out.
[Karen] Okay. Are we ready?
The whole tray's coming out.
I can't get that out.
[Jon] Pretty good. Quite pleased with it.
[Dan] Definitely a meringue.
Look how lovely that looks.
-[Dan] What can I say? It's called talent.
-[Ruby laughs]
There's a few holes and that,
but it's a roulade. It'll roll up.
We're gonna let this bad boy
cool a little bit.
[Noel] How are you?
[Dan] I'm all right.
But no star baker yet?
Yeah, all right, don't rub it in.
But you must be...
-Oh, no.
-...so close.
I'm... Yeah, well, I'm not getting
excited about it anymore.
Yeah, I know.
-That little guy.
-I know.
[Noel] He stands
before you and a star baker.
But I think when people think
who's doing well, they think of you...
-Do they?
-...and they think of me.
[laughs] Right.
Bakers, you have...
[Noel] Half an hour left. Half an hour.
[Rahul] I'm just going to
spread my custard.
[Karen] Just gotta be careful.
I don't want to overload it.
I'm just leaving a gap at the top
'cause it inevitably, like, squidges out.
[Kim-Joy] I like to use a lot of cream.
I want them to taste rhubarb.
Not too thick, though.
I want each bite to have some kirsch
and some amarene.
[Briony] Just gotta do the dreaded roll.
Ah, that's the moment, isn't it?
Where it suddenly might go...
-That's the big...
-Ugh!
-Yeah, ugh.
-Ugh.
You want a nice, tight swirl.
Just like a little cut here,
just to get things rolling.
[Jon] I use the technique called 'hope'.
[Dan] Right, let's go for it.
[Jon] This is the crucial moment
to get right.
[Briony] It's so delicate.
Oh, my God, it's so important.
[Rahul] It's just not good.
[Kim-Joy] I hope that's tight enough.
[Ruby] Roll, baby, roll.
[Manon] It's cracking.
[Rahul] Okay.
[Jon] Boom. [laughs]
Ooh. Nice little roll.
[Briony] Come on, you little beaut.
And breathe.
[Manon] Oh. No.
It cracked.
Stop moving.
[exclaims in annoyance]
Bakers, you have ten minutes.
Just ten minutes.
A bit of leakage out the side,
but neaten it up a little bit
with some nice, pretty, piping.
[Jon] I'm terrible at piping.
-Just cover up...
-Yes.
-...the crack.
-Okay. Cool.
We're gonna put some cherries on top.
This is total improvisation.
I just need to decorate it.
[Kim-Joy] Ahh! Really shaky.
Finally, baking at my level.
[Kim-Joy laughs]
[Rahul] It's the rhubarb compote.
-Why are you down here?
-It's easier. [laughs]
-I've found that my whole life.
-[laughing]
It's the runniest toffee sauce.
A few more for good luck.
[Noel] Don't take this the wrong way...
[Ruby] Oh, for God's sake.
I saw a caterpillar in the zoo,
an exotic one...
Okay.
Looked a bit like that.
I think it was poisonous.
-[laughs]
-[Noel] Good luck.
-Thanks.
-These are my mango spheres.
Calcium lactate and sodium alginate.
And when they go in, they react,
and they basically make,
like, a jelly sweet.
It's called reverse spherification.
Try saying that when you've had a few.
One minute left. 60 seconds.
[Rahul] Uh-oh.
You all right, Rahul?
[Rahul] I'm going to be terribly
running out of time.
You're shaking.
[Briony] If you're gonna do tacky,
go all-in.
[Dan] A bit of gold leaf.
I mean, that's my motto,
too much is almost enough.
I'll just go and quickly
stick my white chocolate on.
Have you still got stuff in the fridge?
[Kim-Joy] My hand is really shaking.
[Manon] Voilà.
[Jon] Quick.
Bakers, your time is up.
Thank you.
That looks great.
Bakers, roll your roulades
to the end of your stations.
[timer beeping]
-Oh, my, my thingy.
-[laughs]
-[beeping stops]
-Sorry.
[Noel] The bakers' roulades will now
face the judgement of Paul and Prue.
-Hello, Ruby.
-Hello.
It's really cylindrical.
The shape of it's even all the way down.
-[Prue] Pray.
-Oh, I'm praying.
[Prue laughs]
You've sort of got a fold
rather than a swirl.
Perhaps it should have been
just a bit tighter.
Okay.
It's beautiful and light.
The flavours are stunning.
It is a piña colada.
The coconut and the pineapple
is just there.
[Paul] It's a fantastic roulade.
Your drink's good. Nice.
[Ruby] Good.
[Paul] Thank you.
Thank you very much.
The theme is dreams, but also passion.
So you go to sleep, wake up
and passion follows?
[Kim-Joy laughs]
[Sandi] Wow. I have to go now, um...
[laughing]
[Prue] It's a real mixture
of absolutely exquisite piping,
and then really quite clumsy roulade.
[Paul] It's very thick.
There is no spiral in there at all.
Yeah.
Flavours are lovely, and I'm really
impressed with the passion fruit curd.
But I think the answer
is to have a thinner meringue...
-Right.
-...and a tighter swirl.
Looks very busy. It looks very neat.
Can't wait to see what the spiral's like.
It's broken up a lot. That's a shame.
That's delicious.
I think your two types of cherries
are a really good idea,
and you got a beautiful balance.
Tastes lovely. My mouth's still watering.
Ah, thank you.
[Prue] It looks absolutely lovely.
[Paul] Nice and even all the way down.
The kisses look amazing.
Thank you.
What you've got is a massive meringue
with a little fold.
There is no spiral there.
[Prue] Meringue's quite chewy.
[Paul] Mmm.
You haven't baked it long enough.
It needed a little bit longer.
However, your interior is delicious.
Smooth, sharpness coming from the rhubarb.
It tastes lovely.
-Mmm-hmm. Thank you.
-Thank you.
I think your roulade looks pretty sad.
[Prue] It's flat.
-Yeah.
-[Paul] Let's have a look
at this, shall we?
[Prue] The actual swirl is there,
but the inside is so soft
-that it's all collapsed.
-[Paul] Yeah.
I think your meringue's
slightly underdone.
-Ah.
-Your outside is the only crispy bit
in there. Everything else in there
is soft and marshmallowy.
I love the decoration.
[Paul] It's so delicate,
and it does look neat as a pin.
You do have a spiral.
[Prue] You have a really good one, too.
I think those flavours are wonderful.
Really fresh, lots of different fruit,
the lime cuts right through
the sweetness of the meringue
and you've got the balance perfectly.
Good. [chuckles]
-Yes!
-Well, there you are.
[bakers applauding]
[Paul] The meringue is very, very good.
You need one hero,
and everything else works around it.
Lime's the one in that,
and I think it looks exquisite.
-Well done, Dan.
-Said well.
-Thank you.
-Thank you very much.
-[whoops]
-Really well done.
Thank you.
[Paul] What you've got is cylindrical.
-But you've just lost that spiral.
-[Briony] Okay, sure.
-Maybe less meringue.
-Okay.
[Prue] What's all that?
That's the golden syrup.
There's a little bit of seepage.
[Prue] Mmm. Certainly
tastes like treacle tart.
[Paul] You do get the pear.
'Cause it sits on your tongue,
and then just melts away.
You've ticked every box on your flavours,
but the meringue's slightly too thick
and you lost the spiral.
It looks great.
I like the egg yolks on the top.
There is a bit of a spiral going on there.
[Prue] I'm longing to see
how the spherification works.
[Paul] Wow.
[Prue] Perfect.
It's a nice little touch, that.
I think it's delicious.
The passion fruit, you've really got
that flavour coming through,
and it's about the sharpness,
it's about celebrating the fruit,
you know.
-Wow.
-Thank you so much.
Cheers.
Cheers, Manon.
[exhales]
I couldn't believe it, a handshake.
I was so, so pleased
'cause that is one of
my most favourite desserts.
[Dan] Couldn't really have
gone much better.
I'm kinda nailing the signatures
right now.
[Kim-Joy] Uh, not very happy.
I just need to take it on the chin
and move on.
[Rahul] Probably five minutes
more in the oven.
Oh!
Still bottom of the class.
I need to do okay
in this technical challenge.
If I perform like that again, then,
as my dad would say, it's curtains.
[Sandi] Dessert week
isn't going to get any easier.
Right, bakers,
time for your technical challenge,
which today has been set for you by Prue,
and it is a '70s classic.
Are they making Starsky and Hutch?
No, no, they're still baking,
but normally this would come
in packet form, so, Prue, any top tips?
Follow the recipe really,
really carefully.
Yeah, so that's helpful, right?
Off you two go.
Okay, Prue would love you to make
that retro-classic, the blancmange.
Oh, my God.
A raspberry blancmange
and must have a wobble.
And if that isn't enough to contend with,
it also needs to be served
with 12 identical
langues de chat biscuits.
You have two-and-a-half hours.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
Bake.
I've not got the foggiest
about blancmange.
[Sandi] The bakers
have the same ingredients...
Gelatine!
...and Prue's pared-down recipe
for the blancmange...
It's that retro,
I've forgotten about it, you know.
...and langues de chat,
a light, crunchy biscuit
often served with creamy desserts.
It's my era, this.
I mean, I was a child in the '70s.
[Paul] Now, when I used to
have this at school,
I thought it was absolutely disgusting.
Yes, it's blancmange,
but it's not blancmange out of a packet.
This is more like a panna cotta.
All the colour and the flavour
comes from fresh raspberry purée.
You are gonna love it.
[Paul] I'll take a little scoop. Whoa.
Mmm. That raspberry flavour is just,
bang, it hits you. It's lovely.
That's nice.
[Prue] They're using gelatine to set this,
so they really are under pressure
because they've only got
two and a half hours,
and they need at least two hours
of freezing first, and then chilling.
[Paul] Now, you're going
for langues de chat,
the typical butter biscuits from France.
They'll be great with the blancmange
because the biscuits
will provide the crunch.
[Paul] Mmm. Crispy and buttery.
[Prue] Delicious.
That's a great biscuit.
What can go wrong with these?
They have to quick in the oven.
They burn in a flash because they've got
quite a lot of sugar in them.
[Paul] I think it's a great challenge.
If that's what it was like in school,
I would have had that every day.
[laughs]
Quite a lot going on in this recipe,
and it's not entirely clear.
"Blitz the raspberries to a fine purée.
Pass through a sieve into a bowl."
[Briony] Nice and smooth.
[Dan] Getting all of that flavour
out of the fruit.
Oh, God.
Remember the bit at the bottom,
that's where you get a lot of the purée.
I think I'll just leave this to drip a bit
and move on to the next element.
"Stir in the raspberry liqueur."
Ooh, she likes it boozy.
Then we've got to make a custard.
Simmer until the mixture thickens.
[Rahul] It should start
thickening any minute now.
[Kim-Joy] It just has a moment
when it's like,
"Yeah, I'm gonna thicken now."
"Add the soaked gelatine leaves."
You let them soak, and it sort of
activates it. It's called blooming.
The gelatine is in there,
so got high hopes of it setting.
Almond extract is next.
"Stir in 300 mills of the double cream."
Here goes the raspberry purée.
It's lovely. It's really bright.
[Kim-Joy] Mmm, that smells so good.
[Sandi] You like blancmange?
[Briony] I've never tried it.
The only thing I know about it, Sandi,
is that it looks like a brain.
-Oh, okay.
-I think.
That's quite interesting. Yes.
This is all I've got, I'm afraid.
Is that the look you're going for?
A bit of cerebral cortex?
[Briony] Then, "Pour into the mould."
Easy as that.
The concern is,
how does it come out of the mould?
But I'll worry about that later.
[Ruby] Here we go. I'm scared.
[Kim-Joy] Ahh!
[Briony] Right, I need to get this bad-boy
in the freezer.
Where is my freezer?
Ooh! Do your thing.
One hour.
[Dan] We've got to freeze the blancmange
for an hour,
and then we've got to put it in the fridge
for another hour
before we turn it out.
Really cutting that fine for time.
Um, make the langues de chat.
[Jon] I don't know
what langues de chat means though.
Manon.
Uh, the cat's tongue.
Do you know what a langues de chat is?
Yeah, it's a cat's tongue.
Is it really?
I've made langues de chat before.
I know what they're supposed to look like.
Tongues.
Why does everyone know what these are?
It just says,
"Make the langues de chat mixture."
No method.
It's just a list of ingredients.
Icing sugar, plain flour, salt, extract,
egg-whites. Boom.
Just got to pipe it and bake it now.
[Dan] I'm quite happy with this batter.
It's what I remember
the batter looking like.
Don't look at me, Rubes. No cheating.
You're such a little tell-tale.
No-one likes that.
[laughs]
"Pipe 12 identical fingers."
I'm going five centimetres. Ooh.
I just want them to all be identical.
So does it say how long?
No. Just says, "Bake."
All right, go.
[Karen] Bake till Christmas?
Bake till tomorrow morning?
Thanks, Prue.
I think they're probably only gonna
need a few minutes.
-[beeping]
-160. I'll give it about ten minutes.
Haven't got a clue.
[Noel] Oh, that's the cat's tongue.
[Manon] Yeah, that's the cat's tongue.
That's all you eat in France, isn't it?
Cats' tongues and coffee.
[laughing] Yeah.
[Ruby] So the next step,
"Melt the white chocolate."
"Add in green cocoa-butter
to colour it mint green."
[Sandi] Mmm.
[Karen] Like the colour?
No. I don't think food
should be that colour, really.
It shouldn't really, should it?
Bakers, you are halfway through
your technical challenge.
It's an important moment.
It's really hard to tell
how the blancmange is looking.
[Noel] The bakers need to
choose the perfect moment
to move the blancmange
from the freezer to the fridge.
If they leave it too long in the freezer,
then the binding agents in the gelatine
won't set properly.
I think gelatine doesn't respond very well
to being frozen actually.
It tends to go sloppy.
My blancmange is still in the freezer
because I don't think it's that set,
and I'm just worried that
when I'm gonna turn it over,
it's gonna... [blows raspberry]
So I want it to be frozen.
So we're nearly there.
[Jon] Just getting the biscuits
out of the oven.
They're huge.
Yep. That's about right.
Some of them are a bit pale,
but they're gonna be decorated as well.
Hide a multitude of sins.
Right, so what does the
instructions say again?
[Manon] "Dip the cooled langues de chat
into the chocolate lengthways
on the diagonal."
[Ruby] It's not very diagonal,
it's more curved.
That's lengthways on the diagonal, innit?
Innit?
[Karen] That's not right.
It's like a banana.
"Drizzle the white chocolate in lines,
midways from side-to-side
across the langoustines de chat."
I think maybe it's all right.
How long... How much time gone?
[Noel] Bakers...
Fifteen minutes till blancmange time.
[yelping]
[Manon] I'm gonna take the thing out now.
[Jon] Seems all right.
Seems how I want it to be.
"Remove the mould from the fridge
and dip it into a bowl of hot water."
Got some water warm there
for a quick slip and slide out.
Three. Two. One.
[gasps] Ahh!
Ahh. I don't really know how long.
Well, it's obviously
softening round the edges.
I'm so scared to turn it out.
I really don't want
to be the first one to do it.
Oh.
This is awful to watch.
Yes!
[Kim-Joy] This is stressful, isn't it?
It's coming.
Okay, I'm going at three, two, one.
All right, is this gonna lift or not?
Yikes.
[Jon] Oh!
[Karen] This isn't great.
It's out, but it's too soft.
[Ruby] Oh, no, he is melty as.
[Manon] Come on, baby. Ah! Okay, fridge.
Oh, what a mess.
[exhales sharply]
Briony's got hers out fine.
Karen's not got hers out fine.
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
It's not looking good.
It's not gonna be good, this.
Okay. Let's try to make this pretty.
Oh, God. It's just trying
to escape off the plate.
[Karen] This is so rubbish.
[Ruby] Where did you slide down from?
Looks like a blancmange.
[Manon] Oh, well.
Bakers, that is it. Your time is up.
Ah. Dear, dear, dear.
[Sandi] Please, bring your blancmange
and your biscuits and place them
behind your photos on the table.
[Noel] Paul and Prue are expecting
a raspberry blancmange
full of flavour, with a perfect wobble
as well as 12 langues de chat biscuits,
but they don't know whose is whose.
[Prue] Shall we start with that one?
[Paul] Bit of a wobble.
The definition has been lost
a little bit on this...
-[Prue] Yeah.
-...but the colour's good.
Great consistency.
That blancmange is good.
[Prue] Very good biscuit.
Not quite langues de chat shape.
It should be a little bit thinner.
[Paul] We've lost a lot of colour
on this one.
And definition. I think
it could have been a bit better set.
[Paul] The biscuits...
[Prue] They look as if they could have
-spent a little longer in the oven.
-[Paul] In the oven.
They could have spent a little longer
in the oven.
[Paul] Hmm.
The colour of this
is really nice actually.
Nice wobble.
-Delicious.
The tartness that comes from
the raspberry. On to the biscuits.
Bit underbaked actually.
This has lost a bit of height
and a bit of colour.
It's not quite set, is it?
-Mm lovely and crisp.
-[Paul] Mmm.
-Moving on to this, um, pool.
-[Prue laughs]
But that's a soup.
It's not set.
Not set. What a pity.
[Paul] Great flavour though.
Biscuits are very good.
This one's actually got a decent colour.
It's just lost a little bit
of definition there.
[Prue] Lovely.
[Paul] Biscuits look pretty good as well.
That is a beautiful biscuit
from a baking point-of-view.
[Paul] Moving on,
let's have a quick look inside
'cause the colour's not bad.
It's a nice blancmange, that.
These biscuits do look good.
Beautifully piped.
[Paul] They're great biscuits.
Okay, last one.
Nice wobble on this one.
The colour is great. Very nice.
Beautiful blancmange.
It's sharp. It's smooth.
Biscuits are very skinny, but very good.
Mmm! Very nice.
[Sandi] Paul and Prue must now decide
whose blancmange and biscuits are best.
In eighth place is this one.
Manon, it's not set.
[bakers laughing]
Right, in seventh place, we have this one.
That's me.
You didn't get the raspberries through
well enough
and the langues de chat are undercooked.
[Sandi] Kim-Joy is in sixth,
Briony is in fifth
and Rahul is in fourth.
In third place,
Jon.
The flavour was absolutely delicious.
Spoilt by rather uneven cat's tongues.
In second place is this one.
Pretty good.
You had a nice tartness,
and the biscuits were nice, too.
Thank you.
Which means this one in number one.
Dan, it really was
the most delicious thing.
Well done. Welcome to the club.
Shut up.
It was one of my goals
to get first in technical.
Couldn't really have gone any better,
could it?
[Manon] Never making a blancmange again.
[blows raspberry] Puddle.
[Karen] I'm really disappointed
with the result.
Do you want me to elaborate?
[Briony] Not a great day.
Plan for tonight?
Go and have a few glasses of wine,
early night,
on it tomorrow.
I feel like
the competition's getting tougher.
A big part of me just has this sense
I'm going home.
[sniffles] Hmm.
[Sandi] There's just one challenge left
in dessert week.
[Dan] Good luck, everybody.
[Kim-Joy] Good luck.
[Sandi] One more chance
to be crowned star baker
and to avoid leaving the competition.
What's so interesting is that
the, sort of, top four,
which is, sort of, Rahul, Ruby,
Jon and Dan...
Dan the Man.
[Prue] Those four have been really good,
and the other four
have all been in trouble.
[Sandi] Briony possibly.
[Paul] Yes.
For sure.
Manon is down there as well.
Something very depressing
about Manon's blancmange.
-I know.
-Looked unwell.
[Prue] All Kim-Joy's flavours
are very subtle.
But neither Paul nor I are very subtle,
we just like great wallops of flavour.
I, I would hesitate to comment.
[Paul] Karen's in big trouble.
[Sandi] That roulade was not good.
[Paul] So I think coming
into the last challenge,
there's a lot of people
who've gotta raise their game.
Hello, bakers. For your
showstopper challenge today,
the lovely Paul and Prue would love you
to make a spectacular,
mesmerising melting
chocolate ball dessert.
-Sounds like a magic trick.
-Well, in a way it is.
So the dessert of your choosing
must be concealed
and encased within a chocolate sphere,
which, when topped with a hot sauce,
melts away to reveal the dessert within.
[Noel] It can be any dessert,
any chocolate, but the textures
and the flavours
must complement each other.
[Sandi] You've got three hours.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
Bake.
Pressure's on because
it's such a complicated dessert.
Not feeling too thrilled
about all of this.
I just need to do a lot to save myself.
I'm just worried.
And it's really hot. Again.
With chocolate.
Oh, my word.
[Manon] I'm working really quick
because I want it in the fridge
as soon as possible.
Thank you very much.
What we're asking for
is the most delicious,
original dessert inside a chocolate globe.
When you pour the sauce on top,
you want the chocolate to melt away
to show the perfect dessert underneath.
There lies the problem.
If it's too thick, it's not gonna melt
all the way through.
If it's too thin, the chances are
it's gonna crack and fall apart anyway.
We're gonna be judging their dessert, yes,
but it's gotta blend well
with the chocolate and the sauce.
So, you've gotta think on two levels.
One, the dessert's gotta be fantastic.
But also, you've got to think
of the flavours
when that chocolate and sauce
is added to it.
That still has to work.
There's a few bakers in the tent
who are in a little bit of trouble.
-So, Briony, your chocolate ball dessert?
-[Briony] Yes.
So I am doing a white chocolate ball.
The dessert encased is going to be a...
An amaretto and blood orange
sticky toffee pudding tart.
Oh, that sounds heaven.
[Paul] So you've done treacle tart,
and now you're doing sticky toffee?
Yeah, and they're both
my husband's favourites, so...
-And mine, actually.
-Yeah?
Oh, good.
[Noel] Briony's tart will be enclosed
inside an imposing
marbled white chocolate sphere,
which will be melted with a blood orange
sticky toffee sauce.
[Paul] Your choice
of white chocolate as the dome,
do you think that's the right choice?
Yeah, I think it works well
because with the dark chocolate,
it didn't compliment the flavours,
it just completely overpowered...
-[Prue] Dominated.
-Yeah.
[Paul] Okay, well, thank you very much.
-No, it's a pleasure. Thank you.
-Look forward to it.
Yeah, thank you.
I know, actually, that Paul makes
a sticky toffee pudding tart,
so...
[exhales sharply]
[Sandi] And Briony's not the only baker
putting her trust in a hidden tart.
I am doing, basically,
a golden egg sitting in bird's nest.
Inside, you'll have a
sweet shortcrust pastry base,
and then you'll have a pistachio crumb,
a white chocolate coconut ganache
and a tart passion fruit curd
with a mango meringue on top.
So quite a complicated
little tart in there.
[Ruby] Yes.
[Sandi] To reveal her tropical tart,
Ruby will make a hot coconut
and white chocolate sauce.
I go out for dinner
with my girlfriends quite a lot,
and this is something that we
would definitely go and order.
You've seen a surprise
melting chocolate ball
when you go out for a meal with the girls?
-Yes. Yes.
-Have you?
Yeah. They're in restaurants now, Paul.
-Yeah, you spend too long in drive-thrus.
-Really?
[all laughing]
You need to get with the times a bit.
[Noel] Rather than a tart...
[Briony] It's really good
to get that in actually.
...some bakers are banking
on a more layered approach.
I'm making a joconde.
This is a toasted hazelnut version
because it pairs quite well
with the peach.
So basically, it's a peach and hazelnut,
like, layered mousse cake.
[Dan] With alternating
peach mousse layers,
Dan's joconde will sit in
a peach-shaped dark chocolate sphere,
inspired by his daughter Constance's
favourite bedtime story.
[Sandi] Why peach?
I was really struggling for inspiration,
and then I saw James and the Giant Peach
on my kid's bookshelf,
and I was like, "I'll do a peach."
-So that's basically the reason.
-You have a little imp that speaks to you?
-Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
-Have you made this before?
-I have.
-[Paul] Has it, sort of, worked?
Yeah!
Your voice is getting higher, Dan.
-"Yeah!"
-I don't know.
Don't know why I'm doing this,
but I've seen people do it.
[Sandi] The layered dessert that will be
hidden inside Jon's chocolate ball
is also inspired by his kids.
[Jon] Making a version of an opera cake
by calling it a "ballet cake"
because my three daughters did ballet
and my two youngest still do ballet.
This is my Lucy and Hannah ballet cake.
[Sandi] Ringed
with white chocolate ballerinas,
Jon's sphere will hide
an 11-layered ballet cake,
which he'll reveal with a hot raspberry
and kirsch syrup.
I love the look of that. Goth juice.
That's what I do for a living.
I deliver blood.
-Oh, you do, don't you?
-Mmm.
[Noel] I suck it out of people's veins,
and you deliver it.
I'm getting hungry now. Is it lunch yet?
These pistachios will make my crumb.
[Sandi] Most of our bakers are making
a single dessert designed for sharing.
The problems with peaches is
either they're beautifully ripe
or they're a bit bland.
[Noel] But with 20 individual desserts
to perfect...
The nuts will be their legs.
...Kim-Joy's boldly going
where no baker has gone before.
I am doing galaxy-themed chocolate ball,
filled with choux turtles.
-Turtles?
-Yes. Turtles.
-[Sandi] Because...
-Because...why not?
-[laughing]
-No, that's exactly right. Why not? Yes.
-It's space turtles.
-Space turtles, yeah.
[Paul] Where do you
come up with this stuff?
I don't know. [laughs]
[Noel] Featuring chocolate orange
craquelin shells
and orange liqueur cream filling,
the turtles will sit inside
a dark chocolate galaxy
until they're revealed
with a salted caramel sauce.
[Paul] The choux,
the caramel, the chocolate,
the whole thing together
should be amazing.
It's a great blend.
-I really hope so...
-Plus, turtles in space.
-I'm trying.
-What's not to love, right?
And with little cocktail umbrellas
as well.
-Oh.
-Of course.
-Obviously. Obviously.
Silly me.
Thank you very much indeed, Kim-Joy.
-[Prue] Oh, she's mad.
-[laughing]
[Dan] Oh, joconde.
[beeping]
[Sandi] Preparing a delicious dessert
is the least of the bakers' worries.
I'll give that another minute.
[Sandi] The judges have demanded
that each one
is hidden inside
a highly decorative chocolate sphere.
[Kim-Joy] So this is gonna be
like the galaxy.
I've got a glove for my cocoa butter.
I usually use it to dye my hair.
I'm just seeing if there's any thin bits
through the light.
[Noel] If the walls of the sphere
are too thin...
You've got to try
and give it a fairly firm edge.
...it will crack and collapse.
Bit of back and forth. Ooh!
[Noel] Too thick,
the chocolate won't melt,
and the theatrical reveal
of the dessert inside will be ruined.
Rather it be a bit too thick
than too thin.
Then the next thing on my list is to pray.
[Sandi] It's a challenge Ruby,
Manon and Briony
have made even harder for themselves.
With a lower melting point,
white chocolate is less stable than dark.
[Ruby] I'm trying to work very quickly
'cause this was just
at the right temperature.
[Noel] To produce a sphere
that doesn't collapse...
[Briony] Here comes
the technical shaking part.
[Noel] ...they'll need thicker walls.
It's very graceful.
The technique is shake it out.
-[Briony] Oh, we have the same technique.
-Yeah.
[both laughing]
[Noel] Manon's white chocolate ball
will hide a French entremet dessert
featuring layers
of white chocolate mousse,
raspberry curd and a crunchy
dark chocolate praline base.
Oh, I'm really hot.
'Cause I put quite a lot inside.
[Noel] Whilst most of the bakers
are using moulds...
Get off. Get off. Come on.
...Rahul and Karen...
Chocolate festival.
...are gambling
on a less rigid approach.
[blows]
Too many cigarettes
when I was a young lass.
My children's party days
are long since gone.
[Sandi] Karen's pinning her future
in the tent
on a balloon-moulded dark chocolate sphere
concealing a raspberry liqueur
chocolate brownie
layered with mascarpone
and raspberry syllabub.
[Karen] It's really important that
this works for me today
because I'm on the edge of the rankings.
I mean, I know in life
it's only a chocolate ball,
but today's it's important.
[Noel] Rahul's taking his showstopper
so seriously,
he needs more than one balloon.
[Rahul] Well, this one,
the practice was different
because when I was making the balloons,
this was not very successful.
The balloons keep popping on my face.
It's a very tricky process.
[Noel] He'll use his spheres to
craft an ornate kalash,
a Hindu symbol of abundance,
said to contain the elixir of life,
or, in this case, a seven-layered coffee
and chocolate opera cake.
I'm literally five minutes
behind the schedule already, so...
[Sandi] I've gotta tell the bakers
what time it is, but I don't know
where Noel's gone.
Um, I'll just get on with it.
Uh, bakers, you are exactly
halfway through
your showstopper challenge.
My peach mousse is
gonna need quite a while to set.
I've got to get a hustle on.
[Manon] This is, uh, raspberry curd.
[sighs] And then gonna make
my chocolate collar.
[Jon] This is the topping for my dome.
It's a pair of ballet shoes.
[Rahul] This is basically some traditional
Indian pattern called "Madukani".
[Karen] I'm making a syllabub.
Well, I wanted a bit of booze in here.
I've put loads in. Probably too much.
[Kim-Joy] Going for strong flavours today,
just 'cause the dark chocolate
is so strong.
Orange is gonna be the main thing.
[Briony] Ooh, he looks good.
That's gonna go in for 20 minutes.
[Ruby] My pastries definitely
look better. They're not gonna see it
it's all getting drenched in chocolate.
[Rahul] I'm just going to start building
the layers for the opera cake.
This is a layer of coffee buttercream.
There'll be three layers of sponge.
Four layers of ganache.
Two layers of raspberry buttercream.
[Manon] It's like precision work.
Yes.
[Dan] I'm making my dessert
directly into it.
I just think if it works,
it's more impressive.
If it works.
[Kim-Joy] I think they look good.
That's lush. I'm pleased with that.
I just need to get on
with the decoration of that ball.
Just gonna get my chocolate sphere
out the freezer.
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
[softly] Sorry.
[Briony] This is as nerve-wracking
as blooming giving birth.
[Ruby] Oh, no, it's cracked.
There. Everywhere.
[Briony] God, this is so, so delicate.
[Manon] Just really hard to open.
It's good. Yeah.
Phew!
It's not cracked. Ah! Yes. Amazing.
Okay.
I'm just gonna punch
some little peepholes.
[Briony] Oh, it's cracked.
[Ruby] Come out, please!
Last one.
Oh, man, this is gonna be a disaster.
I can feel it.
It's going. It's going.
It's going.
Whoa. Oh, no. It's just cracked.
-Ah, you're joking?
-Yeah.
[Briony] It's died. It's died.
[Noel] Too hot?
And, like, once it starts going
underneath, it just goes...
[imitates collapsing]
[Noel] Is there nothing you can do?
[Briony] No. Not really. It's all right.
I'll put it on.
I'll put it on. It might taste nice.
Don't worry. No, I'm fine. You've gotta
laugh about these things, haven't you, eh?
[laughs tearfully] And cry a little bit.
I'm all right. I'm fine.
Oh, no.
[Jon] Take your time.
I've gotta make my chocolate sauce, Jon.
[Ruby groans]
Tell me what to do
with the chocolate sauce.
-Ah!
-[Ruby] You got it?
"Place cream into heavy-bottom pan."
[Ruby] Jon, thank you.
Don't even say, "thanks",
you haven't got time.
Angry.
-Uh-oh. No.
-That looks good.
-It's gonna need a little bit of trimming.
-Like some sort of Russian hat.
[Dan] Jon's... I mean,
I don't know what it tastes like,
but his looks amazing.
So, um, yeah.
Unless you have a chocolate sphere,
whom I can put on my cake,
I'm not sure I can give my attention.
Uh-oh, see? This is what happened.
Okay.
Can you fix that?
I will try, if I can.
[Noel] This looks
like it's very precarious.
I'm gonna leave you. Good luck.
[Ruby] You know what?
We're gonna go with a dome.
That were close.
Okay.
See what we can salvage.
[Sandi] It's just melting
as we're watching.
It's carnage.
Panic, panic, panic.
You call it. One minute.
Give them one minute.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
Come on.
[Ruby] You know what?
Where is that shimmer spray?
Oh, no. My nozzle's clogged.
It's gonna be a very yellow peach.
I'm just adding a splash of gold leaf.
Argh. Don't break now. Don't break now.
Bakers, time is up.
Oh, what a shocker.
[Sandi] Please, place your showstoppers
at the end of your benches.
[sighs]
-That looks great.
-[puffs]
-Babe.
-Don't worry.
Did it melt away?
-Disaster.
-Oh!
[Sandi] It's judgement time
for the showstopping
melting chocolate ball desserts.
Jon, please, bring up your showstopper.
-Oh, yes.
-[Prue laughs]
Come on, people, give it up for the tutu.
[all laughing]
In attention to detail,
I'm in first position as well.
[all laughing]
I think the dome is spectacular.
The shine you've got on it,
the tempering of the chocolate,
the colour works as well.
I think the design at the bottom scares
the living daylights out of me.
It's a thing of beauty.
No, it is not.
-It is!
-[all chuckling]
Can we get your hot-sauce, please?
[Jon] Here it goes.
[Noel] Wow.
Wow. I think we need to get in there.
Clear and distinct layers.
[Prue] Beautiful texture, too.
It's really rich. It's delicious.
I think you've done a great job
'cause the flavour combinations
really work,
the raspberry and the chocolate together
with the opera cake.
-Thank you, Jon.
-And extra points for the outfit.
Cheers.
Do you understand the word "sphere"?
What happened was, it had shattered
into so many pieces,
so I had to do a bit of a jigsaw
to try and have something.
[Paul] Nice reveal.
These are all my favourite flavours.
Pistachio. Passion fruit.
[Paul] It's very thick,
the walls of that tart.
[Prue] Too thick.
It's quite sickly.
[Paul] There's too much pistachio
which dries everything out.
It's very difficult to eat,
-if I'm honest.
-Right, okay.
[Paul] We only wanted one globe,
you've done two,
and it's very elegant.
It's very Rahul.
Thank you.
It's beautiful.
Remind me what's in the sauce?
[Rahul] Oh, it's coffee crème anglaise.
So you first put it on the top, and then
it's slowly going to melt the rest.
I hope.
I'm so sorry.
It probably needed more sauce.
[Paul] It's quite strong, isn't it?
[Rahul] You should have, like,
seven-layer opera cake.
[Prue] Oh, beautiful.
[Paul] Yeah.
[Sandi] Wow.
[Prue] Look at that.
[Paul] It's very neat.
I love that flavour.
Come on, Paul.
It's fantastic flavour.
The coffee chocolate that
you put on the top, works so well
with the opera cake
and the crème au beurre,
as well with the coffee in it.
It's silky smooth, it's delicious.
You did a great job there, Rahul.
Thank you.
-Again. Thank you very much.
-[all laugh]
Thank you.
You don't have to go backwards.
I'll do three steps,
and then I'll turn around.
You can turn around. It's okay.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
No excuses. It melted.
[Paul] It looks like it was too thin.
Particularly white chocolate,
it has to be quite robust.
Okay.
[Prue] It's like a creature.
Elegant, it's not.
But it is lovely, robust, family flavours.
Blood orange is just so great.
[Paul] And the texture of it is beautiful.
[laughs] The outside is a bit of a mess.
Yeah. I'll take that.
[whispers] I think I might be going home.
[whispers] Let's not think about it now.
No, but it's okay. I'm okay.
Hey, it's not finished.
It was supposed to look like a peach.
It looks like a planet.
It's a... It's a planet then.
[Paul] Planet Dan.
[Sandi] Go, Dan.
Nothing for it now. Come on.
Come on.
I'm out of sauce.
It's going, it's going.
Oh. It's going
to go in, not out.
Oh, brilliant. Bravo.
[Paul] Let's take a big scoop.
[Prue] Oh, it is layered, I see.
[Paul] Very good.
-It's absolutely delicious.
-[Sandi laughing]
The tang from the fresh peach
married up with the sweetness
of the mousses
is very, very good.
And the caramel works well
with it as well.
Planet Delicious.
Yeah. Thank you very much.
[Prue] Very neat and pretty,
and I love the piping.
It's a beautiful thing, but I think
what you've done is lovely.
[Manon] Oh, God, this is not good.
-[Prue] Voilà.
-[all laugh]
[Prue] Look at that.
[Paul] That looks amazing.
The collar is so lovely and thin,
and the flavour's lovely.
[Paul] You've got this smooth
white chocolate that sits in the mousse
and then the kick from the raspberries,
it is stunning to eat.
I mean, really delicate, sophisticated.
I think that's a triumph.
Yeah. Well done.
Thank you. Thank you.
[mouthing] Well done.
[exhales]
Well, I think it's wonderful.
Thank you very much.
I think the design is very good.
I think it's highly effective.
[Karen] Come on, baby.
-What's gonna happen now is...
-[Sandi] There we go.
Very good.
Let's have a look inside here.
We've got chocolate brownie,
mascarpone cream
with raspberry liqueur
and raspberry syllabub.
It's absolutely delicious.
I wouldn't say it's elegant.
I think it's hugely decadent.
I do like the flavours.
It's a shame you missed
some of the key ones for me.
I'm not getting too much
of the raspberry liqueur.
It could have been a bit stronger.
Well, never mind. Thank you very much.
Thank you very much.
The whole universe concept,
you've got it. I think it's fantastic.
You've got a lovely shine as well.
I think it's wonderful.
This is the moment, Kim-Joy.
Come on now.
She talks to it as well.
[Sandi] There we go.
[Prue] Oh, look at that.
[Sandi] Oh, the umbrellas inside.
[Kim-Joy] Yay!
[Prue] Those turtles are just perfect.
[Paul] I think it looks amazing.
What's the flavour inside these?
Orange and orange liqueur.
That is very delicious.
[Paul] And what's lovely is,
you thought about how the sauce
was gonna blend with the chocolate,
which goes with the choux as well,
and the whole thing works together.
You've got the slight alcoholic kick
at the back of it as well,
and I think the design is flawless.
-Thank you so much.
-I think you've done a great job.
-Well done, Kim-Joy.
-Ah, thank you.
-Well done.
The comments are like the best comments
I've ever received.
I think Prue and Paul
are sold on space turtles.
[laughs]
It's rich, isn't it?
It was a good one,
and had I had a good day yesterday,
I would have been confident.
I feel okay now,
but now isn't when we're sitting
on those stools and waiting,
and I would be absolutely crushed.
[Briony] Over the two days
I think I'm at the bottom,
but I'm quite of the opinion sometimes
it's better to expect the worst
because then, if it happens,
you're not as surprised,
and then, if it doesn't happen,
winner, you know.
[Noel] Prue and Paul must now decide
who will be our fourth star baker
and who will be leaving the competition.
I have to tell you, I never
want to eat chocolate again.
[both laughing]
Paul's fine, aren't you?
Well, I don't know, um,
I think today with the weather
was a bit tricky.
But what happened was,
when they were pouring the hot sauce on,
I think it worked, especially Kim-Joy's.
Kim-Joy, I think, saved herself.
[Sandi] She needed to.
Dan and Jon have
got to be hovering up there.
I mean, the outside
didn't look great for Dan.
[Paul] But the interior was delicious
with those peaches.
-[Prue]I know.
-Dan's had a good week.
Gotta say Rahul as well.
Yeah, again.
Rahul's there again.
[Prue] The truth is,
it's Dan, Rahul and Jon.
And I want Jon to win on costume alone.
The person who went into the showstopper
with tears and tension was Karen.
She did a very good showstopper.
But frankly, I don't think
she's necessarily saved herself.
[Sandi] Briony's looked the saddest.
Basically what she spent three hours
doing was making a tart.
But we have to say,
this week is very unusual.
Terry is not here.
If Terry were here...
He might have been the one to go home.
...he might have been the one to go home.
Obviously, Prue and I need to
discuss this a little further.
Do you know what's the best thing
about all of this?
Noel and I have got no decision
to make whatsoever.
-We'll just go and play Frisbee, right?
-Shall we?
Yeah.
[bleats]
If my hands get clammy, I'm sorry.
Don't worry. Go for it.
Well done, bakers, another lovely week
with you in the tent.
Now, I get the joy of announcing
who is the star baker,
and if I tell you
that this week's star baker
did a peach of a showstopper,
I don't think you'll be surprised
to learn that the star baker is...
Dan!
[bakers applauding]
Planet Delicious.
Ah, that means I've got the horrible job
of sending someone home.
The person who's going home this week...
is...
...nobody.
-[gasps]
-You...
[laughs]
Oh, man.
[exhales]
[Noel] The judges felt it wouldn't be fair
to send someone home
with Terry not being here, so...
But the downside to that,
means that next week
there is a strong possibility that
two people might be going home.
[Briony] Okay.
Thank you.
And on that note,
it feels weird sending no-one home,
so I'm gonna go.
-See you later, guys.
-[all laughing]
-Bye, Noel. Take care.
-Cheers, pal.
-It's been great, yeah. Loving your work.
-Such a big fan. Bye, Noel.
See you then, mate. Take care.
Oh! Thank you.
[laughs]
I'll be better. I promise.
[Paul] Okay.
Phew.
Oh, that's so good, isn't it?
Do you know what, the great thing,
is that at the end of each show
you get a clean slate.
-I'm freed from the gallows.
-Oh, my God.
I'm so pleased I'm not going home.
My family, they will be giddier than I am.
They're so excited, my two girls.
Yeah. The dog's not too keen.
-Mate, you must have been close.
-Eh.
-It must have been close.
-If I was, all right. Well, well done.
You have to win it next week.
Debbie will be really happy
I'm through to another week.
A lot more stress in the house again.
But, yeah,
I know she'll be really pleased.
[Constance] Hello, daddy.
Hello, Constance. How are you?
Good.
Hey, guess what?
I was star baker.
And how did you get star of the week?
[laughing]
How?
Because I made a cake.
Very good and very tasty?
Yeah, very good and very tasty.
Now, I'm going to play with my doll.
Oh, I love you, too.